nicole belloubet en visite à la maison
centrale de poissy la ministre de la
justice est venu constater
l'effondrement d'un mur extérieur de la
prison survenu le 28 mars dernier
mesurée évidemment les inquiétudes qui
peuvent être celle de la population
quand vous avez un mur d'une prison qui
s'écroule
il y à de véritables inquiétudes que je
comprends bien et surtout envisagé avec
monsieur le maire l'avenir l'avenir pour
la ministre passe par une rénovation du
site la femme politique propose de
débloquer une enveloppe d'environ 60
millions d'euros
moi il me semble vraiment nécessaire
si nous restons à poissy ou centre ville
comme je le souhaite que nous nous
engagions pour la ville et pour les
habitants de cette ville à rénover
complètement ces lieux et à en faire
vraiment une prison moderne secure avec
des objectifs clairs de détention de son
côté le maire de la commune karl olive
propose une alternative déplacer la
prison une consultation citoyenne
devrait être lancé auprès des habitants
de la commune
la question qui sera posée c'est
êtes-vous non favorables au maintien de
la maison centrale en centre-ville
je souhaite le faire d'ici le mois de
juin dans une forme juridique que nous
sur laquelle nous travaillons qui sera
évidemment autorisé la maison centrale
de poissy est installé en centre ville
depuis 1821 il compte aujourd'hui 193
détenus dont 35 à perpétuité